here in my garage just bought this new
Lamborghini here it's fun to drive up
here in the Hollywood Hills but you know
what I like a lot more than
materialistic things knowledge in fact
I'm a lot more proud of these seven on
September the 3rd 2015 Tai Lopez
released his infamous here in my garage
ad and people kind of memed it it was a
joke you're in my garage here in my
garage even though it blew up on YouTube
everybody was being filled with all of
his advertisements on here I am in my
garage here's my bookcase what do I care
most about knowledge what people don't
realize is Tai Lopez paved the way for
an invasion of what you can call
Internet online gurus and if you've ever
tried searching for money related topics
business entrepreneurship the
self-development at this point they're
in so many different niches iconic you
can count but you will probably be
flooded with at some point and add with
them talking straight at you into a
camera telling you that sign up to my
free training free training that I'm
giving you an invitation to and join our
completely free training where I'm just
hurt to attend our free live class today
and register for one of my free
trainings that is happening soon and
there's just so many of them it's like a
copy and paste what you might not
realize is that at first it seems a bit
harmless but some of these people are
earning millions and millions and
millions and then when you really look
into and you realize a lot of these
people have a cult-like following
is Dan Locke a cult yes or no is it hi
to get closer our cult yes or not yes
and then you realize that they're not
really trying to teach you anything you
see the main goal is to keep you hooked
on their products to reprogram your mind
to think that you need the next thing
and the next thing that they release and
the next thing after that all while
smiling and happily taking out your
credit card and swiping it whilst giving
them Millions and making you poorer or
in more depth so do you want to learn
how to replicate it well this is
whatever you're gonna talk about and
honestly I don't really care it can be
anything it can be preferably a fad
something like cryptocurrency let's talk
about Bitcoin or its dropshipping or
beauty about Drive shipping is that you
don't need to carry any inventory Amazon
FBA its consulting I started my
consulting business from scratch and
then grew it to the point right now
where I'm making more than 20 million
dollars per year with or it's real
estate or its sales how does exceed in
sales doesn't matter what you pick but
preferably it's something to do with
wealth or health relationships something
that you can really target people's
insecurities and their dreams you can
actually earn a living without working a
job and I've helped more than 3000
people from all around the world quit
their jobs and I'm gonna show you step
by step how my students are earning six
and even seven figures working from
their laptops from home that's the most
essential point
it doesn't matter if you really don't
know what you're talking about you can
hire an expert get them to write a
script and you can read out to a video
camera
they approached MJ and they were like
hey can you make part of our course for
us because to be clear I don't know why
but my guess is they don't know what
they're doing on Amazon
preferably you have a little bit of
experience that you can give some
general knowledge out there that can
probably be found in a book or if you
google searched it again guys it doesn't
matter about what is in the course
that's not what's important here what's
important is how you market it this is
the stage that separates the bottom tech
gurus from the guys who are actually
making the big money you see it's all
about marketing in this industry and if
you can't market your course properly
then you're not gonna make as much as
you should be you want to start by
running some YouTube ads and Facebook
ads Instagram ads look wherever the hell
you can find people who are young enough
and probably in a vulnerable position to
where they want to buy into wherever the
hell you're selling them which leads us
on to the next point sell a dream you
can make enough money to be financially
free you could be generating profit in a
matter of just hours if not just a few
days running six figures yeah my
students are earning six and even seven
figures working from their laptops from
home the tough goal
financial freedom when I say to what
financial freedom what picture comes to
mind right a beach this year alone I've
have 76 people leave that jobs and
become financially free I was able to go
from being completely broke in dead-end
university to making over 86 thousand
dollars in just my first 60 days
rested in creating a passive income
stream that I'm traveling around the
world been able to do some really cool
stuff trap the world and it's all there
for you if you just click the link below
and sign up to my free training register
for that training join our completely
free training and it's all revealed
right here in this book I'm gonna give
you this for freedom the goal with this
ad is to hook them in you want to really
dig into their emotions you want to make
them feel like wait wow this guy's
earning six figures and he's thrown up a
bunch of testimonials of his students
and I can do this as well sure I'll
click your link got him you see here is
where you lead your prey into the next
stage of your funnel this is where they
enter your webinar your free live event
they buy your free book whatever it is
make sure you keep it a little lengthy
in the case of a webinar one to three
hours you see the longer it is the more
time they get to spend with you and the
more trust they build towards you and
the higher the chance that you can sell
them on higher priced courses
another thing is make sure they're not
distracted if you want to make sure that
that whole attention is focused on you
in this webinar in this moment turn off
the social media to tell your family
leave me alone close down Facebook turn
off Netflix turn off Instagram you know
hide your phone if you need to for the
next 60 minutes because this exact
training has changed literally thousands
of lives and it can do the same for you
now oh hold up you're probably saying
but but James I don't have any
information to tell them what do I teach
these people
come on we're not trying to teach them
anything in these webinars the goal of
the webinar is to make them ask even
more questions and the goal after that
and the main goal is to get them to buy
your course got it
now you want to tell them your back
story your sob story tell them that
you're just like them and you were poor
and there wasn't anything special about
you I never got very good grades at all
and think I was the low average and
pretty much the only thing I was good at
was hanging out with my friends and
drinking beers
growing up I was a loner alone that all
the way through high school and I got
beat up quite a few times tell them how
you hated your job how you were stuck in
the rat race I would literally drive an
hour to work each day I was working as
an accountant working 80 hours a week
depressed anxious it just felt like a
jail cell I felt my life literally being
sucked out of me minute by minute what
you need to do is you need to sound like
you're in the position that they're in
at that current point in time and if
you've done your youtube ads right and
you've probably attracted the most
vulnerable of these people then believe
me there was other failures in between
times when I didn't sleep for months on
end up all night stress the people who
are broke and people who really want to
make money or a young and naive enough
to feel like the course can get them to
that point those are our ideal targets
am I gonna be that broke kid and be like
everybody else in my family or am I
gonna finally step out I felt that I
knew there was more like you know
there's more sometimes you just don't
have the path in the plan it's also
important to know that you want to
rewire their mentality and their mindset
tell them that money is abundant money
never goes away here's the thing it's
not scarce you need to spend more energy
on how to generate the money not save it
it's not going away it's not about the
money it's about the freedom it's about
the time with your family tell them that
there's so much money on there guys
so that when it comes to the point where
you give them the price of your course
in their heads the objection of oh it's
too expensive is already overcome when
they're like but oh he told me the money
is abundant doesn't matter if I finance
this with 2,000 pounds money I don't
have because money's everywhere man
just like he said but here's the thing
you want to tell them that they have to
put in the work right you want to tell
them that they need to be responsible
for what they do I'm only looking for
people who are dedicated to this who are
gonna be focused on this business for
people who are willing to put in work
this is for real people we're willing to
put in real work I need to take action
if you're still with me today you're an
action taker anyone anywhere from any
country on earth can earn a full time
living on Amazon if they're willing to
put in the work listen if anybody ever
told you it was easy to get rich they're
selling you something and they're lying
to you right because it's not easy to
get rich and that's why most people when
they reach the age of retirement right
they can't retire most people you know
are gonna find themselves because when
they buy you a course and it doesn't
work for them you want to make sure that
they're not blaming you that that's
telling themselves you know what it's my
fault that this didn't work now you want
to go for the hard sell show them
testimonials of previous students who
have gone on your course say look here's
Johnny and he made 100 grand in his
first month of doing it so it took him
one year to get to six figures four
thousand dollars from two clients over
fifteen hundred dollars in one single
day $7,800 in the span of about a week
make it sound easy easy easy easy you
don't have to have any experience to get
started gonna have new tech skills to
find your software you need your own
product you never have to meet with an
agent where you never look at a house
you don't have to negotiate the way that
through an agent all those pieces don't
need to be an expert you don't need to
take the risk of failing you don't need
to hire employees or no matter your age
no matter where you live no matter your
circumstances can create a full time
income zero money needed you don't have
to wait for closing it all happens in
about 10 or 14 days it's copy and paste
them into your listing and your PPC
campaigns and it's easy as that but it's
not a get-rich-quick scheme guys make
sure you don't say if we get rich quick
scheme
say everything but it's tough listen if
anybody ever told you it was easy to get
rich it's literally as simple as buying
products for a dollar and selling them
on amazon.com they're selling you
something and they're lying to you right
it's are earning passive income from
Amazon you know sometimes even 30 days
or less because it is not easy to get
rich and that's why most people when
they reach the age of retirement right
they can't retire I'm lazy I don't want
to work hard and I want to make a lot of
money so I mean if you're like me and
you're lazy and you don't want to work
very hard but you want to make a lot of
money then this opportunity is gonna be
perfect for you right for hold on
some of these people still have a bit of
a rational part in their brain which we
don't want some of them are probably
thinking it seems a bit too expensive to
buy a 2500 pound course I don't really
think I can afford that so here's what
you want to do you want to create
scarcity so if you want to get these
additional bonuses you need to join now
and if you're gonna think about it
you're gonna miss out on this these
bonuses are only available for a very
limited time and are only available for
the people who are really ready to
invest into their future today because
once these bonuses are gone guys they're
gone forever for people on this webinar
today only I'm going to do it for one
thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
dollars you can tell them it's okay to
finance it with their credit cards or
whatever that helped the money if the
money is the biggest hurdle but if you
have the desire if you have the time if
you have the willingness we have an
option for you you can actually use
PayPal credit and you can actually get
started for almost little to no money
down it's essentially free today
[Music]
now you can sit back and watch that
sweet sweet profit flying when I say the
word financial freedom what picture
comes to mind right a beach you're
sitting on your city mother what is it I
was about this
swing thing when you're drinking your
way but why stop there
you didn't really think we were just
gonna be selling courses right remember
our goal is to get them hooked on our
products you want to create your ladder
it's not just about the course the
course is the first step the next step
is selling them the mastermind program
which is like 200 pounds a month the
next one after that is selling them to
your live event which is 300 pounds a
month and then sell them on the even
bigger course of better course which is
5,000 you practically have an army with
you these guys have watched you
religiously and people think oh it's
only a course it's only $2,000 first of
all a lot of people to have don't have
to time sorry to say pleasure this is
why I do the show that's 26 thousand
dollars are you listening everyone at
home are you listening make them feel
special with your live events you know
make them feel like a celebrity like
they're actually achieving something
tell them to all dress up in suits if
you have to and tell them they're all
doing well and you're all gonna be
successful and remember trust your guru
[Applause]
now we got absorbed and of course you
don't tell them the truth
right I mean after all we're selling
shovels a gold rush we don't tell them
that the reason we're so damn rich and
live in the life and they want to live
is because we've sold them a dream and
sold them our courses that aren't really
gonna get them there II found a
consistent source of income of thousands
of dollars every month and all he did
all he had to do was sell more access to
himself but I guess you're sitting back
there in your mansion sipping your
champagne and wondering man I wonder how
none of these people have said anything
yet well that's the thing you see if you
remember correctly we told them that
they are responsible for their own
actions
so each course that they buy and each
failure that they get they are the ones
that feel like they're completely
responsible a lot of people can be like
dude you know well that's your fault for
Queen your job but hey I'm one of
hundreds hundreds if not thousands of
people in that program who did the same
thing everyone I knew quit their jobs
I guess parmi was ashamed just like
everybody else a lot of people are
ashamed that's why a lot of people don't
come forward oh yeah oh yeah there are
people watching right now who aren't
gonna come for it's an orchestrated
think he uses your psychology against
you I mean some of these guys are so
desperate in their situations that they
have to believe it's gonna work for them
otherwise the alternatives far worse one
of these guys I knew that was struggling
he handed his Craig card over the two
damn logs lackeys and he said I'm
praying that this goes through
and it didn't he got declined and he
just melted on the floor he was crying
and then another guy was like I got
declined too he's like man if I could
sell my soul right now I would I'm look
out Mike you're joking he's like I would
sure some of these people are in debt
and they falling out with their friends
cuz off the rule you told them to kick
out the negative people and their family
thinks they're part of some college it
doesn't matter at the end of the day you
got your millions right you can sit back
enjoy it and watch your webinar and your
courses all sell themselves the thing is
I don't really have anything against
online courses I think online courses
are amazing in fact they taught me to
edit the video that you're watching
right now they taught me a lot about
marketing they taught me about personal
finance but the kind of courses that I'm
talking about but they're not thousands
of pounds most of them I got on udemy
and they're like 10 quid here and
they're about probably in total I spent
two hundred pounds on online courses
they're not trying to sell me a dream
they're not trying to tell me I'm
essentially gonna get rich quick unless
and that's kind of the problem with I
think a lot of these internet gurus
aside from all of the moral stand points
it's more about the fact that they're
really cheapening one online course
isn't how good online education can be
the next time you kind of come across
these gurus or someone that sells you a
course for thousands really really
question whether the value that they
give you in that course is worth that
money because the chances are you can
find any of this information in a book
or just doing your own YouTube searching
which is probably where they got the
information from anyway
what's important to always look out for
is is what they're telling me the method
in which they got rich themselves one
with most of these people selling the
online course just probably isn't once
you spot the signs that you're listening
to or you've bought into the product of
a
online fake guru just run it's really
not worth it and I mean it when I say
that most of them are just trying to get
you addicted to their products because
after who you are just a number in their
funnel to them and ultimately you're
just the number in their bank account to
them you're gonna see more and more of
these online gurus I think personally a
lot of them aren't gonna last I think
eventually some of them are gonna get
extremely unethical they're gonna be
caught out in some sense well there's
gonna be some kind of regulation but for
your own sake just don't get into them
in the first place
so thank you guys for watching till the
end of this video my name is James
Janney if you liked what you saw please
do hit the like button it helps so so so
much with with the channel with what I'm
doing and if you want to see more
content like this I've got a lot of
exciting stuff planned hit the subscribe
button hit the notification bell check
out my last video as well I did it on
universities and whether it's worth
going to currently in 2020 I think
that's an awesome video especially if
you're in England and you're curious as
to whether you should go comment down
below if you have made it to the end
here I'll respond to all of it I promise
and it means a lot that you have watched
up until this point but with all that
being said peace my friends